Speaker 1: Speaking of Tucker
Carlson. We've talked before about
projection when they talk a lot about
something the left is doing or should do,
really, we should be asking ourselves, aren't they
the ones that are doing it? And Tucker Carlson is
now calling for Democrats to de-escalate their
rhetoric because it might actually lead to,
you know, anything from real world violence to
extremism. Tucker, that's what you're actually
doing. And in fact, when Tucker's rants appear
verbatim in the Buffalo Shooter's manifesto,
you know that he's desperate to push attention
anywhere else that he can. It's projection or
the pot calling the kettle black or, you know,
whatever analogy or metaphor you want to use.
Take a listen to this from last night.
Speaker 3: Because rhetoric has its
own internal logic. Right. You can talk.
Speaker 1: Yourself into things we've all
done that Democrats are doing it right now. And
what they're talking themselves into right now is,
quote, something worse. It's scary. Oh, it is
time to pull back. It is time to de-escalate.
Otherwise, this is going to get really ugly really
soon. Well, it did get really ugly really soon.
A guy just went to Buffalo to search for black
people to shoot because he believed in the great
replacement or white replacement theory, which
Tucker and other of his right wing media cohorts
have propped up. He's talking about the wrong
people. You know, it's a it's almost like he's
saying these satanic pro pedophile Democrats
who are desperate to forcibly inject you with
a vaccine that's killing hundreds of people. Those
people need to tone it down because the rhetoric
is getting dangerous now. The rhetoric is coming
from their side. And one of the most notable
kind of narcissistic traits is these extreme
double standards that include projection and
accusing others of that which they are actually
guilty of doing. It's one of the many tactics
that's often used by narcissists and abusers and
manipulators, and on and on and on. Their rhetoric
already incited an insurrectionist riot on January
six, 2021. They talk about dangerous illegals
against whom we need to be protected, blah, blah,
blah. When undocumented undocumented immigrants
commit crime at a lower rate than Americans,
the constant gun rhetoric we might need Second
Amendment solutions. We might need to be ready to
take up arms against whoever talk of civil war,
which we will talk about a little bit later, and
the belief that they harbor that increasingly
violence is acceptable in order to achieve
political results. It's coming from their side,
save the occasional, you know, eco terrorist or
whatever. It's almost all coming from their side.
We'll have these clips on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.